welcome to philanthropy and action
I am maxim thorn and I teach
philanthropy here at Yale University
today our guest is noted philanthropist
Tim Gill Jim thanks for being here
Tim founded an amazing corporation that
dealt with software called quark and
he's used the proceeds of the sale of
quark to fund his philanthropic works
already tim has spent over 220 million
trying to make the world a better place
joining in the conversation are our
amazingly gifted Yale students who are
here with us today
now to start Tim what made you first
decide to become a philanthropist so I
had never experienced my parents giving
money I think they did I think I noticed
that they went out to college or
something but I never actually
experienced it we never talked about it
and so what typically causes someone to
give away money is some kind of
life-changing event for some people it's
a recognition that you're going to die
soon for me it was when they passed
amendment two in Colorado which revoked
every gay rights law that had been
passed over many many years and in fact
my assistants assistant at quark had
actually voted in favor of doing that
and I came into work and I thought you
know she says I should be able to be
fired for being gay that the sexual
orientation shouldn't protect me and so
I thought maybe I should fire her but
then I realized that that would simply
be doing the bad thing that we didn't
want to happen
and so my business partner actually said
Tim you should give away a million
dollars to teach people the
discrimination is wrong I thought a
million dollars that's a lot of money
but as it turns out I hadn't balanced my
checkbook in a while and I had a little
bit more than that in my checkbook and
is that your first experience with
giving it wasn't the first it was the
first significant one can you remember
the first No
it for the amendment to fight I gave I
put in I think forty thousand dollars
thirty for forty thousand dollars which
was a huge expenditure for me at the
time how old were you let's see subtract
twenty so I'm sure I was fifteen no it
would have been my middle to late
thirties right some so some Democrat
demographic questions that are very
interesting when you study them where
were you born
I was born in Indianapolis Indiana but
didn't live there very long and
ultimately ended up in Colorado since I
was about eight and did you go to
religious school know where your parents
religious not particularly we were
Methodists which is kind of Christian
delight and would you say that religion
had a part to do and how you thought
about your philanthropy no none
whatsoever
were you an activist I had been involved
with the gay liberation group at
university which where was that was
Colorado University in Boulder and I was
office manager and I went around and
spoke to classes about what it was like
to be gay you know had been gay for all
of six months when I started talking to
classes about what it was like to be gay
but right well we have a question so
we're going to go to a question online
mr. Gil do you consider it more valuable
for a benefactor to contribute his time
or personal action to a cause rather
than to donate money the answer is both
so there are things that I'm involved in
that I actually go and do things and
help out that's less true now than it
was when I was younger but nothing could
have there's no way I could have had 220
million dollars of impact with just me
going stuffing envelopes so that's at
some level you want to have that
connection to things so that you
understand what they are so that you
understand how organizations work but
for me just because the amount of money
I got was so overwhelming giving money
is probably the smartest thing I can do
and actually 60% of my assets were put
into the Gil Foundation
shortly after I formed it do you think
about that ever losing touch as a person
with what is actually happening or do
you think because of your comparative
advantage as a skilled business person
that you're better playing in that space
out of touching my way if one is a
campaign worker you should you're
licking envelopes making phone calls etc
and if if you're at the donor your tend
to be somewhat removed not necessarily
but right would be no and I'm certainly
removed from some things there's some
things like internal politics that I'm
happy to be removed from but it ended up
being able to think about things at a
higher level and I also end up not
getting this happens in any organization
when you're embedded in the organization
you can become involved in kind of very
internalized thinking that doesn't
necessarily move the ball forward and I
don't have that restriction because I'm
never thinking about what it is that the
organization is doing now I'm only
thinking about what I want the
organization to do in the future we have
another question
question is what is that a filament
failure how do you know what need to be
changed okay and so in this particular
case the question is me failing or you
mean something that I want to fix
externally I because both happen I mean
I've done several things that have
failed miserably yeah so there's a
couple things that happen and some of
them are natural okay so it's perfectly
natural for me to assume when I get into
funding gay and lesbian issues that the
people who've been in it for years and
years and years know more than me and
that they're gonna make smarter
decisions at some point I've been in
that business longer than they have and
so I know more than them and so then it
becomes something where I'm partnering
with people and where I want my ideas to
be treated appropriately which doesn't
mean they have to do what I say because
it's not like I can give you several
examples of things I've done that have
failed I tend to be super experimental
and so I'm perfectly willing to try
something with a low probability of
success but if it succeeds it'll be
really cool but we've changed so that we
I actually tend to I'm a mathematician
so I like numbers a lot and what I want
to know is how many people's lives I'm
affecting and so to me the definition of
success is how many people's lives I've
changed how many people have a better
lived experience over time and that's
more important to me than feeling like
I've done the right thing the
philanthropic community is really good
because so every single organization
that's fun that raises funds
has someone whose mission in life is to
make you feel good about the
organization so you'll give them money
so they set up essentially a social
network that you can easily get sucked
into and so if you become friends with
them then if you all of a sudden they
aren't being efficient anymore and you
defund them you're defunding a friend
and that's hard and they want it to be
hard but ultimately that's not the very
best thing for the movement from my
point of view I want to fund the things
that work good good
building one on what you said though do
you think that it's because of your
business acumen and strategy that allows
you to frame things the way you just did
which is to say if something even if it
has a low probability of success
I might have outlier rewards because
that's that's a that's a different
strategy that I would hear from other
heads of foundations and perhaps one of
the distinctions is the donor isn't
alive anymore do you know you have you
noticed that and why yeah living donors
are tend to be much more experimental
often or they at least tend to be much
more idiosyncratic I'm sure there are
several people that describe me that way
but as soon as when the donor dies then
everyone wants to kind of deal with the
legacy of the donor and so you could
hear them asking questions like so what
would Tim want and I really don't want
them asking that question I really don't
believe that someone you know 20 years
or 50 years from now could project what
it is that I'd want
hi my name is Esther Chen my question
for mr. Gill has to do with measuring
the success of our interactive gaffers
I mean class we discussed how much more
difficult it is to evaluate the impacts
of things like social justice effort as
opposed to the so my question for mr.
Gill is in your campaign for greater
LGBTQ rights and equality how have you
defined success and what has it look
like so oh there are some things that
really are truly hard to quantify but
not as many as you would think and so in
the case of gay rights what percentage
of the American populous of the gay
American populace could get married and
that's a really simple quantifiable
thing you fix it by passing laws in 50
states so the nice thing about those
kind of qualifications is they're easy
the thing I'm not a big fan of is
quantification that's hard because you
see foundations that spend a huge amount
of money on measurement and in the end
if you would take find a way to spend a
smaller amount of that on measurement
and spend more of it on actually doing
whatever it is you want to do it would
have a better result there's one
organization that's starting in Africa
and its mission in life is to
essentially help improve the economic
life in these very very rural villages
and they're doing it by giving money to
women not to men because they might go
out and do something silly with it but
the women are responsible for you know
maintaining the household or starting a
small business and their measurement was
to do it once see how it worked and then
the cost of measuring it is too high and
so they don't measure anymore they just
give the money away so it was
fascinating but they did do the
measurement once you have a follow-up
question Molly
do you follow up question Tim on this
don't you think though that for a lot of
funders who have spent a lot of time
being pressured to develop metrics
mm-hmm find themselves paralyzed to fund
social justice because the time horizon
could be quite long to achieve the
change of hearts and minds related to
race or gender or sexual orientation or
identity right and that that's the nice
thing about the gay and lesbian movement
at the moment is because the rights
physically aren't there they aren't
there by law this gives me a really easy
metric it would be a harder metric it's
all it's a much harder metric for racial
justice because the the laws say that
color doesn't matter it's the practice
that's the problem and so that's a much
much more difficult measurement problem
and you end up getting snarled up in
causality issues like our African
Americans poor because they're African
American or they just historically poor
and if I were operating in that space I
think I might have a little paralysis
trying to figure out how to move forward
it'd be a much much harder issue well
one of our students
Derek wrote a really brilliant paper in
this class and he makes the argument so
Derek you're gonna follow up on what I'm
about to say he makes the argument in
this paper that there is data to support
the idea that part of what makes people
philanthropic is the community they live
in so once you reach sort of this forty
percent threshold of a in which there
there there is a mixture of wealthy
people and non wealthy people used you
see a clear statistic of people becoming
more philanthropic if it's mixed when
you when you get a well level of wealth
that is a beyond 40 percent people tend
to be less philanthropic right and this
is easily the 1% to 5% middle class
Americans etc so the argument would be
the more people interact with people
across socio-economic classes the more
philanthropic like they would be we have
a case that's going on in Texas in the
Supreme Court right with the University
of Texas that is about removing race and
other diversity measures as a metric in
in accepting students to the University
of Texas with that kind of of data would
that move you as a philanthropist to
engage in that conversation which
conversation the conversation about
ensuring that you have diversity knowing
that there are outcome measures that say
people actually are more tolerant of
race or tolerant of sexual orientation
and so forth if they're in fact into
commuter and but diversity is an is an
outcome measure it's also an easily
measured thing which is the wonderful
thing about it we did a we're in the
midst of doing an experiment where we're
trying to put gay people on boards of
nonprofits in Colorado and so what you
do is you call the head of the board of
the largest foundation in Colorado you
say so
and you they have maybe 20 people on the
board so we're doing an experiment or
we're doing a survey to see what the
experience of gay board members is like
in Colorado can we talk to the game it
member of your board and there's silence
and so that's one of the things that
we're actively pushing is that the only
way that ultimately gay people get
treated equally in the society is when
society sees them contributing to sees
them in the same places doing the same
things that they are I think the reason
people will go back to to this because
I've heard this thesis before about why
rich people are less philanthropic and
let me give you a couple of things that
happen and people can respond to them in
different ways so the reason the gill
foundation has 60% of my assets was
because we did a conference for
philanthropists
and you know I'm just sitting there in
the hall talking and this older guy it's
reasonably well-off guy said you know
the older I get the less money I want to
give away because I'm afraid I might
need it and so basically his as he aged
he became more fearful and so my
solution what I said huh that must not
happen to me and so that next year I
gave 60% of my assets to the foundation
just because of something this one guy
said the other thing that happens and
this happens to me too
and I alluded to it earlier my business
partner said Tim you should give away a
million dollars to convince people that
discrimination is wrong and I was going
a million dollars just a lot of money
but it wasn't and the problem was that
my mindset was not where my assets were
and so to me a million dollars was a lot
of money I my dad was a doctor so we
were reasonably well-off but wait a
million dollars was a lot of money and
so there was a growth process I had to
go through to learn what a lot of money
was and what a lot of money and what
wasn't a lot of money for me and so that
happens too but the other thing and
you're absolutely correct is that when
you isolate yourself so that you're
exposed to nothing but people who would
just like you then you don't look at the
world correctly anymore you don't focus
on the correct problems there's a really
horrible awful video that I've just
watched in the hotel called the queen of
Versailles about what happens when
people get too much money too fast and
don't know how to process it
after watching the video I spent a lot
of time trying to decide whether there
was any little bit of this family at me
it was a very they had not adapted to
their new money well
I was worrying him how what someone just
said informs have you go about promoting
LGBT rights because I think historically
there's understandably been a reluctance
of some in the LGBT movement to engage
with the other side with social
conservatives who maybe we think will
never take their minds we're really not
gonna get much headway with having
discussions with them but I think
there's also on the other hand an
argument to be said that without
engaging with people who may be a
partner sympathetic to your viewpoint
there's really not gonna be any progress
in ever making a substantial social
change yeah I mean so go back to the 50s
no one was on on our side I was I was
very small then but no one was on our
side so everyone was our enemy and you'd
have to engage somewhere and the problem
is there are enough people on the side
of gay people now that you can become
very comfortable and say well I'll only
deal with liberals or Democrats or
whatever but I've hired two extra
Republican ex mayors we routinely try to
find Republican candidates to fund this
is not philanthropic this is the see for
parts of my operation and there are five
percent of people who are irrefutable
forever our enemy and everybody else is
our future friend and the only question
is what trajectory Rhian to change them
from where they are now to being our
friend and to do that you have you have
to go places that are uncomfortable and
you have to find the things that that
people connect with and sometimes it's
sometimes you just have to make them
think make them meet meet their
constituents make them actually sit down
and talk to their family members but you
have to have a lot of those
uncomfortable conversations do you think
that's a special privilege or a burden
or what for you I'm an introvert its
burden
and yeah so for example when the
marriage debate was going on in New York
I desperately wanted to be there and the
problem is that that tip for them Tim
isn't a person tim is this evil outside
entity that's trying to do things to bad
things to them so I was actually
forbidden by my own staff to come
because it would have politicized the
environment even more than it was
already politicized for me to be
physically there and they would have
been able to put a newspaper story about
me having a back room conversation with
somebody that would have been very bad
PR let's go to another question my
question to you is you often fund
campaigns that tend to be controversial
on the ground the example that comes to
mind is the mooing dog campaign in
Colorado and while you say you know such
a campaign is just meant to facilitate
dialogue there's obviously a certain
degree of information that goes on with
either counter campaigns or news media
I'm just wondering whether this
defamation has an impact on your donors
whether you see a decrease or an
increase in donors or whether you sort
of have to make up for you know the
potential losses it's such a defamation
could you okay so my donors are me and
so the real question is do I become
myself and the answer is occasionally
the mooing dog campaign Norman was if
you haven't seen the commercials -
Norman the dog that mood was an
experiment and so the the contention was
that people so people use as an argument
against gay people will they make that
choice they don't have to make that
choice and so Norman was a dog that mood
he didn't make that
choice and it was really quite explicit
that that was what was going on when
those commercials were going on and it
those were run in one to I think three
different communities those commercials
one was Colorado Springs because focus
is on the family was there and why not
another one was it was kind of a more
there was a West Western town in
Colorado and there was one other non
Colorado town and then there was a
control city where we didn't we ran
questionnaires but we didn't run the
commercials just to kind of see what
happened and as it turns out when we ran
those commercials it swayed a few people
you know in our direction and it swayed
a few people against us and it swayed
mostly the older people against us if
you looked at the demographic breakdown
but then entertainingly enough so that
was like basically people's immediate
gut reactions if you went back and did
the same survey two years later after
the commercials all of a sudden the
numbers started to swing worse
significantly in our favor than in the
control cities so it was just a
fascinating experiment it was not a
scalable experiment the cost of doing
something like that and on a nationwide
basis is too high but it was an
experiment I wanted to perform so it
ended up being quite fun but it didn't
affect any of our donors because that
would be me now will you have a question
related to whether Tim polls and so
forth
but I also had another question sort of
about you do on the other Gill
foundation and then y'all Center the Gil
Action Fund which is seafloor
organization right and I'm just
wondering sorted on how you break down I
know that Gil foundation one of the
stated goals is to advocate for equality
since I was kind of wondering the
distinction between what those two
organizations can do in terms of
political speech and active in the
political arena and sort of where that
line is
so the Gil Foundation is a private
foundation public foundations have
little a little bit different rules
they're allowed to do a certain amount
of lobbying for example and a private
foundation can do absolutely none so as
a private foundation in fact as a
private foundation
I can't even register voters I can give
money to other public foundations to
register voters but I myself cannot do
it directly so when we want to do those
things that are slightly more political
some of that them can be done by public
see three entities and will grant grant
money out to do that as a private
foundation we can do any polling we like
so any data that we want to collect we
can collect we just can't go and we
can't register voters we can't lobby we
can however talk to you can talk to
legislators about things that isn't up
for them as a bill so if you want to
talk about gay life in general or
something you could do that and
similarly the one place you kind of can
Lobby is with in government there tend
to be agencies there are federal
agencies and we have an active operation
that lobbies the agencies of the federal
government I think Congress is pointless
at the moment there is no point in
spending money lobbying Congress but the
way the Affordable Care Act is being
implemented in terms of how it treats
LGBT health issues has been changed
because we have people in there lobbying
on that to make sure that those funds
are spent in an interesting way
we didn't was that that was that was
literally the guilt foundation okay not
to action for that know that you can do
that that's that's just education okay
okay
I'm not because I'm not telling someone
how to vote it's not as as soon as soon
as you get down to telling someone how
to vote on any issue whether it's a race
whether it's a ballot initiative it's
typically see for you can do educational
things prior to ballot initiatives that
are talking about the issue without
telling people vote Yes or vote no but
the rules on that vary from state to
state so you have to be really careful
about what you do our next question
did we miss that one
information on which organizations is
best taken to their money too in terms
of creating
and I guess going on with that my
question is how do you
so the gill foundation's mission I wish
I had the original mission statement
went on for like two paragraphs the new
mission is to ensure equal opportunity
for all people regardless of sexual
orientation or gender expression so it's
fairly broad and in the c3 space we
unless we have a particular project
we're trying to fund we tend not to say
this is a organization as good or this
organization is bad per se but there is
an organization which is housed inside
of us that's funded by us and others
called the movement Advancement Project
or map and it goes out and evaluates
organizations from a purely fiscal point
of view to see whether or not they're
spending too much money on fundraising
and it compares them all so we provide
that to people as a mechanism for making
sure they aren't giving money away to an
organization that's hopelessly
inefficient but in the end someone wants
to fund their passion and so I don't
want to tell you this is a bad passion
for you to have well this is a bad
passion because they're all things that
need funding and you if you don't fun
what speaks to your heart you're not
going to be as generous as you would
otherwise I just want to make sure that
organizations are efficiently run and as
it turns out some of them were and some
of them weren't
but part of that was they never had any
metrics to compare themselves to and so
that document that we produce is just as
valuable to the organization's as it is
to the donors because the organizations
that say gee how come we're like in the
bottom quartile of this and how can we
what can we do to change that or in some
cases there are reasons for being in the
bottom quartile of something and but it
gives the board something to talk about
it makes the board more capable of
engaging in its fiduciary
responsibilities Tim I want to ask you
about that there's a raging debate in
philanthropy given the war for talent
mm-hmm
so one mindset is that people involved
in philanthropy take a vow of poverty
that in fact they will be paid in in in
in lesser pecuniary terms than people in
in engage in the market or even in
government and then there's the other
side that says you're paying for talent
and so they should be comparable and
Bruce Cohen who had spoken here said
that was one of the reasons that they
went outside of the philanthropic sector
when they hired the lawyers to argue
Perry versus Washington right that if
you're trying to save the world's
biggest problems how why are you trying
to do it on the cheap right we you know
if you're trying to solve the issue of
discrimination against LGBT people if
you're trying to solve issues of global
global health why should that be why is
that a cheap thing when we think it's
okay to do market rate for an iPhone
which some would argue is sort of less
valuable to human existence than getting
rid of some dreaded disease or violence
against gay people how do you come out
on that debate so if the answer is that
you absolutely have to hire the best
people the best people often are not the
cheapest people now that doesn't mean
that we're going to get into a situation
like corporate America has gotten into
where they pay millions of dollars for
someone who
is probably not worth millions of
dollars I think the number of people
that are worth millions of dollars in
the world just for their 40 hours a week
is pretty small and the rest of us are
worth less you know there's just not
that much time and though I mean I'm not
that smart so yeah so I'm happy to pay
good money to people you get people you
typically hear that people you know
they'll do their business career they'll
learn as a collection of skills and then
often as in retirement they'll want to
get involved philanthropically and they
know when they do that that they're
going to come in at a lower pay scale
but it shouldn't be too terribly much
lower for the same kind of function
because they're doing exactly the same
things some of my PR people didn't come
from philanthropy they came from
politics which has a much higher pay
scale but I absolutely need their skills
and I can't just say take 20% less and
20% is not an issue one way or another
if someone's paying 2 3 4 times what you
can get otherwise then that's too much
but we should be paying good competitive
rates when we can you have a question
Scott our next question
hi my name is er and diverging zebra I'm
a singer Foundation has invested around
220 million doctors dedicated to none
doing much much smaller scale many lives
and dealing with a variety of issues but
it's always traced about the process
that needs to allow these organizations
so what is what are the essential
qualities decided or that you decided
she writing right before and I know when
you do come with organizations
I decided which one of them gets more
you know something's curious about
whether or not there has been
organizations like you considered risky
or really innovative that you still
considered supporting and why that is in
okay so there are startup organizations
tend to be much more risky it tends to
be someone with a vision and so
absolutely you're rolling the dice this
is it's exactly the same with a startup
company in technology you're rolling the
dice a start-up tech company and
technology may come if you're a venture
capitalist to say I'm going to do X and
the venture capitalist funds them really
because partially because they believe
in X but partially because they believe
in that individual and almost every
company by the time they finally come
out with their product it's not what
they said they were gonna do in the
first place so what you want to make
sure is when someone realizes that their
initial idea was only half-baked do they
have the ability to define another idea
that they can actually execute on that's
good so that startups and startups the
way you fund startups because they don't
have any monies you tend to be a bunch
of their money so you have presumably
a pot of money you get to invest at one
time the chance that a startup will
succeed and get on its feet in one year
is potentially small and so the risk you
have in funding startup is that you
can't go around and fund them next year
as distinct from funding a more stable
company so that's something you should
consider when we're looking at other
organizations there's a couple of
different things is do I want to fund a
project if I want to fund a project it
may have a particular price and so I can
understand what that price is
if I want to fund general operating
there's a couple of different things I
will do one is
for me sometimes will fun things for
five years so I would never want to be
40% of someone's income because that
you're five I decide you know they're
really not doing the right thing
I'll stop funding them and all of a
sudden 40% of their money's gone they
have to fire 40% of their staff so I
never want to be a super high percentage
of anybody's total income if we are a
super high percentage then we tend to do
a several several years worth of ramp
down grants so that they can adapt and
the other thing that you can consider
and I don't know how effectively this
will work for you but we do it quite
commonly is do something called a
challenge grant where I will say I'll
give you $20,000 if you can get match
you have to get $20,000 from one other
person you can get thousand dollars from
you know 20 different sources and that a
it doubles my money but it has several
other effects that are useful to me so
when we we have something called the gay
and lesbian fund for Colorado which
never funds gay and lesbian things it
funds the symphony it funds children's
vaccinations it funds everything that's
not gay so its mission is really like
Nike okay so Nike why does Nike fund
philanthropic activities I'm sure that
they have their hearts in the right
place but it's also about advertising
and so in my case what I'm doing is I'm
advertising the gay and lesbian
community and so when I give $20,000 at
the symphony them you know we appear in
the program book yeah it's great
okay so we get a little mention but we
can also if we spin that as a challenge
grant then in their newsletters they're
talking about the challenge grant in
some cases they're calling people
they're sending them letters they're
saying the gay and lesbian fund for
Colorado will give us $20,000 if we can
match it can you give us some money to
help make that match and the most
extreme example of that was National
Public Radio or well it's Colorado
Public Radio actually where we fund
their on-air campaigns so the first time
this happened the idea was that we would
do a challenge grant during drive time
and so we were all braced because we
thought the homophobic listeners to
Colorado Public Radio will call up and
fill the phone lines with vitriolic
hatred and nothing well and it will be a
very bad experience for Colorado Public
Radio but what happened was stunned
silence from the homophobes and all the
gay people and the gays and that people
who are gay supportive heard it and they
were going Oh My gods we're part we're
an integrated part of the community and
that was their best fundraising our ever
when we did that particular challenge
grant so that's something you can
consider too is that you can take your
money potentially and find a way to
challenge either students at Yale or
some other constituency that you have a
connection to so that you can give away
more money than than what it is that
you're allocated do you think when when
you are making these determinations that
it is more important to have a great
idea or or is it to have someone that
you believe can execute I say this
because some of our other
philanthropists say there were lots of
great ideas but no limited capacity to
execute on it and that they invest in
people the passion and the people even
if it's not necessarily the best idea
that is out on the market sure how do
you come down on that well I mean it is
their idea after all so even if it's if
it's completely terrible then you don't
have any confidence that when they come
up with I did number two that it's gonna
be any better so you want it to be at
least a pretty good idea even if it's
not perfect but absolutely you are
looking for good people because the good
people will learn from the good people
learn from the failure and they move on
and they don't make that mistake again
the bad people don't learn from their
failure could you talk a little bit more
about because I think this is really
fascinating and different about failure
do you find failure problematic
and failure is problematic only when it
happens all the time
if if we don't fail so people will say
if we don't fail we aren't learning
anything and we can give you so I can if
if you want success I can
let's take politics because politics is
much easier to do this with because
politics has a very definite end point
where Canada is elected or not elected
if you want to spend pick a number
you know how did thousand dollars you
want to invest it in political
candidates that are good on gay and
lesbian issues I can give you a docket
to spend a hundred thousand dollars you
will have a hundred percent win rate and
you can feel very good about yourself
because you got those good people
elected it will turn out that if you
didn't invest $100 thousand dollars they
wouldn't all gotten liked it anyway
similarly I can give you a dot that that
you can spend a hundred thousand dollars
on candidates who all have their hearts
in the right place and they're doomed
there none of them are gonna get elected
and I'll tell you that spending the
hundred thousand dollars in either those
ways is useless what you want to do is
you want to find the people in the
middle where you can make the difference
between success and failure and it
applies to philanthropy to is find those
organizations where what you do can make
the difference between them winning and
losing and when you do that you'll have
a win ratio so it won't be a hundred
percent if you don't take enough risk
it'll be a hundred percent if you take
too much risk it'll be to zero percent
so the question is how much risk do you
take that kind of optimizes those
successes you have to create those
successes that wouldn't otherwise happen
Zack you have a question that you sent
in
yes yes the difference is between your
evaluation processes if you have between
national organizations that you fund so
how you these kind of similar so the
other questions but specifically whether
whether you take a different approach to
the different scales you do so one tends
I don't I'm trying to think of it's
really scale of organization that makes
a difference or if it's something else
because it startups you're taking a risk
you don't even sometimes know what the
metrics are gonna be until you're
partway into the process with some
organizations if they do a really good
job there's some some where I just give
them a grant I understand that they're
going to do something with it it's going
to be good we evaluate the organization
as a whole we don't evaluate the results
of a particular grant and then there's
other things which are project grants
where we typically I mean in the end the
the project belongs to someone else
so it's not my evaluation the question
is what's their evaluation and so part
of the whole grant making process is
asking them how are you going to know
whether you succeeded and if you don't
succeed what are you gonna change and so
the question is have they thought about
how they're gonna measure have they
thought about what failure looks like
and do they know how to respond I know
that Derrick has a question related to
your choices between state and local and
fed
we went about the work that you do and
he characterized your approach as we've
seen primarily on the state and local
level and kind of leaving the national
scene and not trying to pour a lot of
money into an initiative that maybe
wasn't everyone it happened I guess but
have you ever feared that donating on
the state and local level won't be
enough and that what's really needed to
push LGBT rights forward is major
legislation or change on the national
level so there's a couple things to
remember the first one is that I'm not
the only funder and so one of my
calculations are if it's is this gonna
be funded regardless of whether I do it
or not
so for some things it's not that it
doesn't need to be done it's that I
don't need to do it and so funding at
the local state and local level is
something that people often don't do so
for example Iowa you can pick any of it
well let's pick Illinois Illinois which
now has civil unions the reason I don't
know he has civil unions is because we
got donors from out of state who didn't
know anything about Illinois politics to
put money into Illinois in a way that
changed the legislature to make civil
unions possible and so in essence I
spent a bunch of money on evaluation in
Illinois about what was possible how you
would accomplish it and then actually
negotiating the process to Shepherd it
forward so that would not have happened
without me and by me in this case I say
me but it really is we I mean I didn't
actually do any of this so this was the
Gil Action Fund but that wouldn't have
happened otherwise and that's that's why
I liked it as opposed to say going and
putting money into a congressional race
congressional races are fine they're
very expensive your money unless you're
giving a ton to independent expenditure
campaigns is irrelevant but the thing is
there are a number of people in Congress
now who started out in state government
and when they were in state government
they we knew their record we could
support them then we could keep them in
power we could give them a bility to
have their views expressed and
essentially build a name for themselves
so that they could make that leap to
Congress so when you invest in the local
level you think of it as like job
training so we're engaged in a job
training effort to train people to come
to Congress that have a better outlook
on gay rights then perhaps many of the
members do now now that said while I
don't spend money on congressional I
should say that's not true I do spend
money on congressional races but not a
lot at a national level there are still
things you can do so
the lobbying that we do with federal
agencies on how the Affordable Care Act
is implemented and any of a variety of
other things the Census Bureau is doing
a is doing does population surveys those
include gay and lesbian questions
they include actually with luck they
will include a transfer so that's
something that you can do as a c3 is we
can help the it seems strange to be
giving money to the government to do
research but in essence that's that
that's what we were doing so that they
could get their trans question answered
so that when actually went on the ballot
they knew on their questionnaire they
knew how to ask it in English they knew
how to ask it in Spanish because they're
not direct translations so they had to
actually do a lot of research to get it
right Tim in your mind when you are
engaged in this work writ large mm-hmm
do you think of yourself does it make
sense to you in your own head when
you're thinking of social reform or
reform movements that your political
activity is separate from your
philanthropic activity or are they all
philanthropic to you one you get a tax
deduction one you don't just does that
do you care about that
okay so when I said I gave 60% of my
money it was to the c3 and there was a
tax deduction associated with that it
was lovely but but you know you don't
make money with tax deductions you only
spend less so and initially I said you
know politics is dirty I don't want to
get involved in politics plus it's not
tax deductible and so that plus it's not
tax deductible was I think the thing
that pushed me over the edge into
initially not funding politics and there
are things for which you don't need to
fund politics or that you rarely need to
fund politics but social change is not
on that list social change you have to
be involved politically because in the
end you want to change the system that
supports things so if you take aids
funding for example a huge amount of
aids money comes out of the federal
government and so a small investment in
lobbying on how that federal money gets
allocated can make a huge difference
that's not particularly what we're into
but that was one of the arguments that
actually was made by another
philanthropist called Jeff Seraph about
why I should be in politics and I looked
at Jeff and I said yeah that may be true
but I don't care and then five years
later I'm funding politics who had a
question on money in politics
okay well for sponsoring were you
involved in any sort of super PAC giving
or anything yeah yeah not at the tent
you know now that the hundred million
dollars levels or whatever their casino
guy is but yes so but don't feel worried
about offending me because I think
they're terrible
disarm from it but sort of given that
these super PACs are now illegal
entities do you feel like perhaps that I
guess made me feel it shouldn't even but
do you feel that perhaps like 501 C 3
you should now be permitted having the
same rights of speech as like a super
PAC okay so what happens during this
presidential season is a bunch of money
flows into politics which means it flows
into pockets of people who do mailings
and run television stations and
newspapers etc etc etc so it's an engine
of the economy
I suppose the economists can probably
talk to us about that but it's really
not it's periodic it's not it doesn't
create sustainable jobs so I'm not a big
fan of it and I also think that we're
giving people too big a voice and you
know the fact that everyone has the
right to have free speech doesn't mean
some people should be given a megaphone
so I would make it go away if I possibly
could but given that it's there we've
used them super PACs are just kind of
the latest version of this but there
have been independent expenditure
campaigns of one kind or another for a
long time the first thing that needs to
happen with them though is the fact that
the donors aren't disclosed is flawed
and I think the donors to any single
anything that's going to communicate
with people certainly and probably
really all donors 2 C 3 s and C fors and
independent expenditures should all be
disclosed and it should all be disclosed
in a really super timely manner it
donors don't like that they want to be
anonymous so that they can hide their
biases behind this corporate shield but
it's not a good thing for the country
that's a really bold thing for you to
say isn't it how someone who also I
think honesty is a really lovely thing
for someone who whose mark in the world
of philanthropy is about aggregating
donors because you have done something
quite creative in the way you have
packaged
philanthropy in a way you have created
social justice as a fund to invest in
the language you have used has adopted
business language and hedge fund
language and you've aggravated folks yet
you say that I mean and you've invested
in impacts yet you say that we should
have transparency we should disposed it
those donors wouldn't that affect what
you're doing and what has made you so
successful in changing the world and
lives for LGBTQ people it might but you
know that's okay
if the rules change then you adapt you
know when when the Gil at when Gil
action gives money to something the
presumption is that it's Tim Gil and so
I don't have I can't hide that anyway
and for political campaigns all of those
donors you disclosed so the number of
things I give to there are a number of
things I give to that are non disclosed
but even this the c3s which are not
which don't have to disclose their
donors we disclose them in our annual
report so all most of that most of what
I give gets disclosed anyway sooner or
later it's just it really should be
sooner
do you actually instead of me asking
this there's a question about the kinds
of donations that other donors make
feasibly your investment in social
justice people who are giving to various
kinds of museums and so forth we had a
question on that what I'll ask you do
you do you weigh social justice as more
important than say just investing in
monuments investing in museums investing
in infrastructure investing at any
number of things that you can invest in
why is that is or is it or is it recover
late but that's okay so there is I said
earlier you should find your passion and
my passion one of my passions is social
justice when I started doing this
the number of people funding at this
level the number of people still funding
at this level is small - when I started
it was non-existent my first challenge
grant failed because I assumed there
were lots of rich people giving away
money at much higher levels than me and
it turned out to be false but I don't
think funding museums or when we do we
fund all we fund those things I don't
think any of them are bad things
maybe funding National Organization for
Marriage is a bad thing but other than
that you really need to fund your
passion otherwise you won't be committed
to it in the long term and so you see in
our funding stream you see the gay gay
funding which is a huge part of it you
see the gay and lesbian fund for
Colorado which funds like I said
vaccinations for kids and arts programs
and a variety of other things and that's
because I'm interested in all those
things - I'm not so one-dimensional that
I have exactly only one interest I do
prioritize that interest and I
prioritize that interest primarily
because there aren't enough other donors
in that space that's becoming less and
less of an issue and so I've started a
little bit of funding for other passions
that I have around mathematics and
computer science when you think about
being a philanthropist do you think that
what you have done is created a model
for making people more philanthropic
aggregating donors who may never have
been donors or who were donors but into
the space of social justice that you've
done is it about creating metrics that
people can figure out where they would
have the greatest impact what do you
think your legacy is legacy I hate that
word you know I just want to do good
things and with donors what I the way I
look at is this we have a periodic
meeting of donors we communicate with
donors and one of the things we
discovered was especially for donors of
inherited
wealth they often pick up the passions
of their parents and they so they're on
the same museum boards the same school
boards and especially and they tend to
be older that they and their if they're
gay they you know their parents may may
or may not know they may be afraid of
funding in that way and so one of the
things we do is give them a peer group
we give them a peer group of other gay
funders so they don't feel so alone I
really knew no other major gay funders
when I started doing this and the out
giving program was created purely
selfishly for me so I could meet other
gay funders and so that I could share
their experiences gained from their
wisdom but the result has been that some
people who who were in that space of
giving to things that didn't feed their
passion but fed their parents passion
all of a sudden had a space where they
could one person was 90% funding of a
certain to arts organizations and a
particular school and two years later it
was that was down to 30% and the other
70% was gay and lesbian stuff because
they had a peer group and they had some
place to share I know that Monica you
have a question on Tim's time horizon
for his foundation
there as you I'm sure know there you can
sort of establish your foundation either
as one that plans to spend itself out
within like a specific time for you or
one that's going to last forever right
and we've sort of discussed arguments
for and against both I think it's an
interesting argument that if you plan to
send yourself out within a specific time
frame maybe you know you're giving it
your all and you're gonna like
accomplish the most good possible now
and leave future problems for future
generations
but there's something to be said on the
other side you know to sort of have that
an institution in place that will
forever be like carrying on the fight
for a certain cause so what are your
thoughts on this and specifically I
guess with the social justice movement
and foundations in that space what do
you think is more effective so there are
things that absolutely need to be funded
in perpetuity museums parks physical
things that you want to maintain social
justice for me you know what the social
justice causes are now I know what
they'll be 50 years from now 100 years
from now I'm clueless and if the gill
foundation lasted forever then after I
was dead the Board of Directors would
continually be saying and what would Tim
Gill think about this and their first
they will in some cases they will never
have met me they won't really understand
my passions they you know right now I'm
living breathing adapting changing my
mind and they won't have that option
they'll be trying to model this very
static thing so I originally set the
expiration of the Gill Foundation would
be 20 years after my death which will
probably be by hitting a tree
snowboarding
but then I read out but Tim you enjoy
giving away the money and so you're
gonna miss that last 20 years of joy we
should just move that up in time so two
years ago we said that the expiration of
the foundation will be in 20 years and
so we've got 18 to go and there are a
couple wrinkles with that because when I
die there's still a corpus that of money
that I have that will go to charity and
so how we deal with that is unclear if
if I live longer than 20 years then the
Gil Foundation won't exist so where does
the money go so that's the issue I've
created for myself the other issue is a
purely economic issue and which is
managing money to last term in
perpetuity is comparatively easy there
is a spin rate you can establish that
almost regardless of market fluctuations
will allow you to to grow your corpus
over time and lots of people have done
it but when you want a trajectory that
hits zero in our case 18 years from now
a mad radical down fluctuation in the
market can screw you up so that's an
ongoing dynamic management challenge we
now have that we wouldn't have if we
were managing perpetuity so for example
we spent twenty million dollars was our
budget for last year and this year it's
reducing to sixteen because what we did
is we upped our budget specifically in
2008 when the economy went down and a
lot of dollars dried up for nonprofits
we kept our budget at the same level and
then kept increasing it slightly just to
kind of soften that blow a little bit
for some of our nonprofits but it's been
entertaining
do you find that the argument you just
made for a sunset foundation has
persuaded others to do the same we
haven't talked about it a lot so I don't
know do you think it's important like I
said I think there are things that
shouldn't that don't sunset but they
tend to ultimately end up as public
foundations rather than private
foundations
I think Ford would probably be appalled
at how his money is being spent and it
in retrospect if he could do it he would
maybe he would try to fix it
contractually or maybe he would have
just said to spend the money earlier I
don't know right
so Kara you get to ask the last question
from the students okay well I was
wondering it seems like you feel about
the secretary the private woman
and foundations cover a very large range
of issues and you think that which
issues do you think that private
philanthropy deals with best and dresses
best and which ones you think are maybe
out of its scope and maybe best handled
by well surely government can do
everything better
no I think you know foundation
government needs to essentially please
an awful lot of people with what it does
and it's never going to do very edgy
things and so I think as much as
possible government foundations should
do the things that are edgier things
that you know you didn't you wouldn't
think that what is it postcards from
Buster is that the name of the old
public television show that was almost
defunded because it had a lesbian couple
on one episode so that was an example of
something that they considered edgy at
the time and the Republicans almost
defunded National Public Television over
it so you want to until society's ready
for something like that you need to keep
that in the private sector you want to
push some of those things into the
public sector when you can but in social
justice our mission is to make those
things not edgy my mission is to make
gay people not edgy and gay people are
much less edgy than they were when when
I was in college do you think building
on Cara's question then do you think
there's a rule in the non edgy space to
do what people caught used to call I
don't know if they still do gay ink in
other words the commercialization of
some of these things is that the
sustainable way to incorporate social
justice when people talk about social
venture capital and and so forth you do
you are you are you an investor in that
kind of stuff
so so venture the application of venture
capitalism to philanthropy to me was
nothing more exotic than a donor circle
it just had a different sexier name but
you know that's about getting a group of
donors together to think about a problem
and I'm in favor of that just because so
just like when I hire you know you want
to hire somebody that in their area of
expertise is smarter than you I
shouldn't be able to go to them
typically and say well you know you
really did this wrong because this this
and this and this and they should be
able to say no no Tim you're completely
wrong that this wouldn't work in this
wouldn't work in this one work so that's
the thing I have to deal with is that I
have in the foundation I have a huge
amount of power and if I say the wrong
thing it might inadvertently send the
foundation off in the wrong direction so
when you have a group of people together
discussing things you get a better
result so I'll give you one example of
there was an organization in Colorado at
a cocktail party I said it would be
really interesting if and I don't even
remember what the if was but three
months later there was a proposal from
that organization to do this thing that
I had said after the word if that had
nothing to do with their mission it
would have been a wildly stupid thing
for them to do and it was just because
of a little casual cocktail party
conversation and full disclosure one of
the greatest moments of my life occurred
in 2009 if you remember Tim the
n-double-a-cp was celebrating its
centennial and there was the Centennial
convention in New York City and at the
Centennial dinner in which Julian Bond
got the Spingarn Medal and President
Obama gave the the speech Tim Gill and
and a number of other significant
philanthropists in the space of social
justice where others specifically gay
social job okay so we're at that Center
table with the chairman of the n-double
a-c-p
at that particular moment in history
launching the second century of social
justice and change and equality so for
that I thank you so much for helping to
make that happen
now let me tell you the back story that
it was I tried to do that once before
and it didn't work which was many years
ago we had something that was
essentially an african-american
initiative and we had a Pacific
Islanders initiative and my vision of
how the money would be spent was that
would be spent to get african-american
gay people integrated and in positions
of power in their own community and that
would be spent to get Asian Pacific
Islanders integrated in positions of
power of their own communities so that
they actually had the ability to
influence things and then in typical
kind of foundation fashion they said no
no we should have a community meeting
and pull all the constituents together
to discuss how the money's given away
and it ended up going to organizations
that made no difference they were there
was no discernible effect from that
$500,000 because it was spent by this
process this very cooperative process
I'm not a big fan of that kind of
processing this man I'm used to like
making decisions and you yes you let
groups make decisions but you but you
were responsible for giving them the
direction quite often and so anything
where the group kind of gets to do
anything they want you don't necessarily
know where he's gonna end up and that's
the leadership that has made Tim Gill
well I think this one of the century's
greatest philanthropists and there's no
question that you have been inventive
you've been moved by passion you've used
your time talent and treasure to change
the world so thank you so much for
joining us here and this has been
you